et on le sait on le regrette parfois
l'apparence physique l'esthétique prend
une place de plus en plus importante
dans nos sociétés jusqu'à présent la
chirurgie était surtout mis en avant
aujourd'hui un nouveau marché est en
pleine expansion
les traitements légers comblement des
rides injection ma mère la médecine
esthétique se banalise avec un chiffre
d'affaires multiplié par quatre en dix
ans c'est le dossier de cette émission
il est signé laurence beauvillard bernie
mériaux laurence ne met pas ses seins
pas assez de volume
il y à un mois elle a essayé une toute
nouvelle technique sans chirurgie une
injection pratiquée à l'heure de la
pause déjeuner en 20 minutes une médecin
m'a fait deux injections par st et on a
ensemble décidé du modelage on va dire
et la proportion et les fêtes et tout de
suite
sang tan et autre cliente avant et cinq
jours plus tard un beau résultat mais
les médecins mettent un bémol il faut
surveiller ses premières patientes et
gaieté d'éventuels effets secondaires
ok parfait dans mon combat c'est sous la
douche comme ça cette méthode
autorisée depuis janvier dernier suscite
un engouement énorme
les spécialistes sont rares est débordée
par les demandes
le produit utilisé ces de l'acide
hyaluronique
c'est une une injection de volume sur
mesure à l'endroit où on veut entre la
glande le musc la technique coûte 5000
euros avec une piqûre de rappel tous les
18 mois
car le produit résorbable et les fait
diminuer la demande en médecine
esthétique légère a été multiplié par
huit en dix ans et peu importe le prix
la technique la plus pratiquée c'est
l'injection de botox pour traiter les
pattes d'oie la base du nez et le front
ses 250 à 400 euros
autre possibilité pour combler les rides
c'est encore de l'acide hyaluronique
ce produit est aussi très efficace sur
certaines parties du visage
alors les filles ont un peu les
pommettes d'accord et les lèvres pour à
sion pour des pommettes je vais prendre
quelque chose
un acide hyaluronique et paix avec une
viscosité importante pour que le produit
reste bien en place
je peux le faire alors que pour les
lèvres il faut quelque chose de beaucoup
plus fluide est beaucoup plus fin les
prix sont libres aux factures à la
seringue 350 euros pièce ici la patiente
a réglé deux seringue
résultat immédiat pour un effet naturel
vous sentez faute vie
deux clients sur trois sont des clientes
mais les hommes réclament aussi leur
droit à la beauté ici épilation
définitive de la barbe ou laser à 100
euros la séance n'est pas remboursée
parce que c'est du bien-être et du
confort donc c'est normal que comme si
on va chez le coiffeur si on va dans un
restaurant on assure aussi nos frais de
vie ce centre le plus grand d'europe
il y a des lasers pour tous des petites
veines que l'on supprime un tatouage qui
disparaît des traces d'acné que l'on
efface les techniques cher qui nous
promettent d'être plus beau plus jeune
plus longtemps cicatrices ont depuis
lors